adesso che fa un freddo porco
effettivamente una nuova scusa buona per
rimettermi sti minchia di cappelli il
fatto è che io li metterei anche
d'estate perché io non soffro e caldo ma
per me caldo non esiste il problema
ragazzi che quando fa freddo inizia a
venirmi il raffreddore a manetta e
tant'è vero che da quando vivo da solo
non riesco a star dietro ai fazzoletti
per che definisco tutti in tempo zero e
sono costretto a usare la carta igienica
come fazzoletto si non è così efficace
in effetti va bene a tutti ragazzi e
benvenuti a questo lo vedo io sono fa vj
vasso ragazzi se vi ricordate di cluster
track day perfetto ecco bene alla in
poche parole bisogna saltare da un
camion all'altro non così mentre
saltiamo da un camion e all'altro
bisogna arrivare al traguardo che quello
lì infatti suo livello un po una cagata
quindi va bene siccome ho già fatto un
episodio di sta roba quindi sono
abbastanza studiato sul gameplay eva x
cosa succede
forse ragazzo fatto camion parkour però
dovete stare calmi c'è ragazzi
ricordatevi di star calmi quando giocata
sta roba per l'amor di dio
cosa succede se ho fatto credo più in
che credo più che cazzo sta facendo
questi sta inglobando una roccia regola
number one mai guardare un camion che si
accoppia con un altro oggetto perché
finite nella merda la cosa strana
ragazzi che sto gioco quando lo dico ma
perche si deve inglobare la roccia
quello anche problemi c'hai vabbè è
perfetto ok mi casa vi è questo qua è un
casino come livello c rispetto agli
altri
se sto fermo dovrei arrivarci però anche
importanti a volte anche star fermi se
qualcuno non ti incula grazie il
problema ha visto gioco che non capisci
su quale camion devi saltare perché
cosa stanno ma perché ma come va più
alto border mi chiama tris con quale
fisica non fate domande ragazzina
nessuno ha visto la fisica di questo
videogame va bene così l'importante
riuscirci al primo tenuti a quanto
succede che riesco al primo tentativo
ragazzi se non c'è un orgasmo c'e
veramente sono vivo sono vivo perché
alterano milano la patente porca eva non
vedete come sono bravo a cavarmela in
autostrada qual è il problema perché
devono volare i camion quali problemi
dite che l'ho preso nelle palle donne
che state guardando questo video voi non
troverete mai la sensazione di un calcio
nei [ __ ] fortissimo però questa sì
questa era in faccia ho vinto ho vinto
da morto a me dai vale se vinco la mort
ovale tv è più il nome ragazzi valeva
anche da morto e cioè non è un problema
in teoria su moglie che i problemi solo
perché sono morto come se io al volante
non fosse già abbastanza un pericolo ok
e vabbè ma che cazzo maschia troy le va
bene io dal raffreddore sono passato a
questo quella di avvicinare le due
montagne è stata la reazione delle
ragazze che hanno guardato il video
nella parte in cui ho detto che non
proveranno mai il dolore di una botta i
[ __ ] sono state loro me l'ha mandata
lo so lo so ragazze che siete state voi
lo dovete stare calmi non troverete mai
il dolore di una botta i [ __ ]
addirittura le rocce che rotola non mi
sembra non mi sembra un po esagerato le
rocce porca eva stavo scherzando va bene
c'è il prof la cosa bella di suo gioco
che non puoi anche guardare cosa ti
arriva addosso devi solo pregare che non
ti colpisca ok io ti ringrazio c'era
l'insegna che era fatta di cemento
armato è andato anche il secondo mondo
ragazzi che a questo son forte winter e
clement l'ho detto è per una volta nella
vita perché ci sono nei mega prezzi mi
copre su un camion in bocca però sono
ancora vivo ecco ho tentato di fare una
cosa bruttissima
e che se farlo a fare che cazzo farlo a
fare quando c'è il professionismo nei
giochi porca [ __ ]
comunque i ragazzi io l'ho io li odio i
prezzi al giusto per dire cioè non è una
colpa non può pagare quando hanno
sviluppato il gioco completo hanno avuto
mania di grandezza secondo me ok
porca [ __ ] lo vivo perfetto tardare a
cadere minchiata ammazzo la madre
meraviglioso amiche e grattacieli me li
ricordo questo l'avevo fatto ve lo
ricordate no che poi tra l'altro c'è
come se essi lo ricordo pure ci ho messo
una vita e mezza a fare questo no ora
non ce la farò mai più a di farlo ciò
che solamente un anno e mezzo dove puoi
arrivare anche sul tetto di stucco è
infatti mi ricordavo ok ok veramente
porca [ __ ] vice lavezzi a mezzo vecchio
vizio nazionale
non ci posso credere non ci credo ci
avevo messo una vita a farlo la prima
volta non ci posso credere
in teoria raga questo come dovrebbe
essere anche un rating della serie ti
devi incazzare quando non riesce a fare
le cose meglio riesco a farle che
presento questo video all'esame di guida
me la danno la patente subito perché chi
cazzo de sa fare speculazioni ok
[Musica]
perfetto
non so neanche come va va bene così
perché c'è mica al contrario allora sei
meglio te è difficilissimo cioè prima
devo arrivare ma come ma non ci arriva
e invece fermi pian piano ok qua volta
fa oa da fax il better game the call of
duty casa sta succedere a se ma
takeshi's custer non c'è un tipo di
istruzioni che ti spiegano come
sorpassare ce l'ha fatta ce l'ha fatta
pesoli sull aiuto troppo presto c'è
detto chi terra muore invece non ce l'ho
fatta
dicevo quando finisco sto pec di livelli
lascio perdere perché mica è impossibile
ringraziando iddio non ho fatto neanche
troppe figure in me ha posto zio magari
mi preoccupa un po più di me stesso che
dite perfetto perfetto può a mio dio gli
orgasmi orgasmo orgasmo ias furbesco è
così che si conquista la [ __ ] ragazzi
miei va bene così solo per curiosità
ragazzi solo per quello
macché e va bene darth vader perché c'è
un countdown che succede
oddio fermi a se arriva 0 partum i laser
e cielo nel culo avevano capito veloce
cavolo è stufa il tempo lo fai tempo ok
perfetto nicchia sempre i fichi e no no
non posso
e invece e invece va bene così cosa
succedeva niente spuntano i laser
fantastico ce la posso fare ragazzi se
non sono fortissimo sono già livello 3
cazzo
solo laser freschi presi ad amsterdam
perfetto lo sto facendo e quello che sto
facendo più velocemente di tutti non so
perché c'è volo sono skillato in questo
non ho capito perché ma va bene ok ok ma
sono io è più semplice questo non sono
io che sono forte sono io che sono fuori
che culo sempre più culo no ragazze
vinco che ho avuto un culo sfondato c'è
veramente culo sfondato ma ancora ma
degli haters 4 riotto sono quasi alla
fine non ci posso credere
c'è veramente gli ho fatti tutti in una
decina di tentativi neanche ecco
ma e non si può fare a ok lo aspettano
non ha funzionato non funzionano e
regala impossibile quindi devo provare
non proviamo senza era più facile del
previsto
la faccia feroce la feroce la francia
300 tua madre e troy non riesco a
passare da un e va bene ci stanno
togliendo tutti si apre al mio passaggio
4 di dieci arriviamo alla fine c'è più
un bordello qualche a casa dei mails va
bene va bene va bene va bene va bene va
bene voleva bene
e vabbè che puttanata era fatto dei
bordelli prima poi arrivò all'ultimo la
stronzata varie case che scemi ma
gazzoli spero che vi sia piaciuto a me
personalmente tantissimo compresi i
laser che mi stanno simpaticissimi per
il pollicione ap se volete anche il
prossimo episodio seno andate finite
così raga non trovò telecomandi potrebbe
essere un problema ce lo dirà fermi
scusate spero che vi sia piaciuto
ragazzi cose io metto le cuffie alla
fine perfetto se non sia giunto il
momento è un mi piace anche la pagina di
facebook e come aiuto alla descrizione
servizi discreti ci diamo un postino
vinto dai ragazzi